olá a todos ah o meu nome é victor é um
prazer enorme estar aqui e agradeço
imenso
o convite ao ex companheiro falar aqui é
sobre os boatos a ea forma como é que os
lados mudaram a minha vida e no
tratamento de esgoto e ficavam é que o
campo o que aconteceu foi como é que os
lados
não era minha vida profissional e isso
começa inscrição como wars aceitar não
fui estudar jornalismo para coimbra e eu
tenho o objetivo de ser jornalista como
alvo vista por cento visão ser muito
rico e acho que me engano a inoã na
profissão porque o jornalista não não
vamos sair vamos ser ricos a partir da
visão era um sítio certo ea equipe da
minha vida que a minha vida muito começa
a acertar nos por começa a estudar
jornalismo e estou há três anos estuda
jornalismo em coimbra até que também vai
sair pro meio ano na sua venda acabei o
meu curso e eles em si uma em janeiro
2014 após ter licenciado e de ter
percebido queremos um jornalismo que eu
queria fazer porque eu gostava sempre
precisa saber que eu quero fazer e que
eu fiz tenho nem todas as associações
estudantis em todas se as associações
nós temos nós temos visões temos temos
rádios e temos jornais em que podemos
para fazer a nossa prática e o que eu
aproveitar e foi já estou treinando
sempre me ajudou a perceber mesmo seja o
mesmo que quero fazer
a e era aí eu gostei mesmo do curso terá
aí aprendi muito como vou aprender muito
no curso de jornalismo e eles em cima no
início de janeiro 2014
eu acabei o curso se encontra a equipe
seja na lista apesar de ter uma pessoa
como dizia que nunca mais esquece que
era os jornalistas trabalham muito e
ganha um pouco e mal em si an de pessoal
portal e mesmo que eu quero pra mim
havia a este meu objetivo que eu tenho e
é assim que vou fazer mas eu e
sentimental em janeiro como nos diz que
entre janeiro e julho e penso fazer o
que eu penso que a gente pensa depois a
concurso
marcos então alguma coisa pareça eu vou
pra viana onde a dança natural é neste
momento a viver em lisboa mas eu nem
estava no castelo e vou para casa dos
meus pais e entra júlio entre junho e
julho semana com isso um trabalho normal
com contrato ou recibo verde a ou então
um estágio profissional também está na
boca ou então estágios não remunerados e
aí foi assim durante sete meses à
procura de emprego e nada parece e
confiança nem com estágio remunerado ou
seja nem de borla não querem quando foi
apagada é que vai ser bonito ea e foi-me
foi mesmo e foi mesmo assim não apareceu
nada e viviam em 17 meses 14 frustrando
cento pensa se eu aceitar o dinheiro e
eu a trabalhar e ia tanto acho que eu
trabalhei tanto para conseguir isto os
meus pais pagaram estudo e de repente
estou aqui em casa e ele vai fazer uma
pergunta simples que não tenha resposta
à pergunta era o que é que vai fazer
amanhã eo e não tinha perspectivas
nenhuma do que queria fazer e eu eu
tinha claro concentrar na minha
licenciatura e eu e meu pai perguntava
minha mãe uma coisa básica não tem que
fazer amanhã eu não sei vou pesquisar
vou procurar e eu tive em jornais e
revistas para procurar a procurar e não
falar que só nacional e teve mesmo local
uma coisa regional ia e nunca surgiu a
oportunidade e eu penso assim prontos o
jornalismo não é pra mim você não
consegue arranjar de jornalismo e não
posso ficar em casa e não me perguntarão
todos os dias o que eu vou fazer eles e
dar a resposta
e é neste momento a pesquisar na
internet que vi gostar dos lados farías
deu sua vida e pensa em um brutal
então vou a vamos pagar a pelo menos
lados vou ter que fazer a publicidade
aos lados vou pegando país a vender os
lados
o objetivo foi entender os lados era
muito ingênua e pensava que é bom que os
que comiam que eu acho que tudo que vem
desse jeito pra mim mas não o que é k
como venho eu sei porque não gosto muito
dos votos
ainda por cima da marca que agora
representa o que eu passei na minha vida
foi a camisola a atm olá é um programa
de verão dirigido a jovens dos 18 aos 25
anos em que temos um objetivo é ser
vendedor ambulante um curso de
jornalismo e agora vou aparecer na em
casa minha mãe fazê-la em arranjar
trabalho e ela então quem vai fazer
agora eu vou vender os lados praia
agora lyon com isto mas foi das melhores
preços que tenho na minha vida e
recomenda a toda a gente anda a fazer
camila dá nos chilenos oportunidades
desenvolvermos nossas competências que
aprendemos no curso e é uma coisa muito
boa e eu só acreditam e não acreditam no
nosso valor ia faltar mais uma empresa
assim que nos dão a oportunidade de
durante tantos anos a estudarem e agora
durante o verão basta os meios para
ganhar dinheiro e para as turbinas
aí eu pegar suas coisas e que consiste
no caso a camila camila conta disso é
vendedor ambulante andar pela rua há
naquela praias a pôr a parcos e as
coisas a mala térmica tem placas com as
lacunas lá dentro também os karts as
bicicletas desolado e vamos fazer
durante um grande verão é vender
ambulantes vendem os lados ambulantes
pelas praias e e pelos jardins como
objetivo de defender mas o máximo dos
lados possível isso aqui tem algumas
faltas como podem ver e então fiz nesse
caso estava em viana do castelo que a
minha terra onde vendia onde estava a
vender os lados
foi uma grande experiência para mim como
podem ver pela beleza mas também eu
tenho um segundo filho estava muito mais
magra por fechar aquela bicicleta é
bastante pesado e vou levar muita pena
falar que nunca mais à frente uma
pergunta que dava tudo isso e que
gostava de saber se vocês conseguem dar
uma resposta
então eu participo na camisola durante o
primeiro ano eu participei com colegas
meus amigos disse o objetivo é vencer o
máximo de jogos possíveis e há sempre
aquela pergunta que se impõe que é como
é que nós enviar na
também devem reconhecer como um evento
de cunho na praia enquanto janeiro um
clipe para estamos a comer alguma coisa
pro canto então aí a tentar desviar a
rua
estamos a desviar como é que nós em
viana vamos conseguir vender mais latos
que no algarve que nunca fazer um bom
tempo
os turistas nesse caso não participou
atípicos que vendem os lados lado só por
si não precisa fazer nada como é que nós
enviar nós vamos conseguir mais votos do
que no algarve mas não pensa não podemos
pensar nisso pensamos uma vez dissemos
vamos vender mais lados que o al gharafa
nós temos uma equipa nós somos quatro
momentos nós temos uma equipa
completamente motivava e focados nos
nossos objetivos
nós não assumimos a camila com um
trabalho de brown e vamos ganhar o nosso
dinheiro
já camila como um futuro para nós e é
uma mensagem nos dá isso é em tudo o que
nós fazemos
eu falo por mim nós tentamos dar o nosso
melhor e isso é muito importante porque
seremos conhecidos mais tarde ou mais
cedo em 2015 como estava a dizer foi um
projeto que o tamanho que os dois lados
não estamos presentes em todas as festas
estávamos presentes na alemanha em tudo
que era para vender volta a portugal a
nós tínhamos eventos em santa luzia que
vocês conhecem em viana do castelo
quer num topo do monte é que eu tenho um
evento e pensávamos e parte vai ter
muitas vendas
mas como é que nós vamos aquela
bicicleta lá pra cima
o evento começará às duas nós éramos
capazes das 10 da manhã
agora bicicleta os quatro até acima
usados alterou a as placas mas viemos e
foi assim que conseguimos nem mesmo quis
ganhar a menina camila
para além do solo que nós ganhamos
ganhamos um estágio no unilever e nós
pensamos
acho que a partir de agora vamos
conseguir ter algumas oportunidades
sejam bastante úteis por nosso futuro e
prontos regionalismo mas quem sabe
provável dos lados ea verdade é que
agora vive dos lados de 2010 é só isso
como o total em 2015 descido primeira
experiência
voltamos a participar neste ano em 2000
e 2015 é desculpa
consigo convencer a minha namorada
participar a e ela possível comigo e
conseguimos vencer novamente o estádio
não leva nem vítima de 15 anos vendendo
muitos lados em 2016 teremos o dobro
ele ajuda os colegas que está teve que
ir para o fluminense
comigo está agora também não é para
fazer o trabalho eu tenho que manter a
gestão necessária não se tratava de
gestão
aí tá na área das vendas ian em 2016 eu
penso
pronto já em 2015 2014 já foi vendedor
em praia feminino dor em carrinhos dos
lados na na rua e eu acho que posso ser
supervisor da academia lá porque nós não
com promotores nós temos os supervisores
que os jovens problemas quer problemas
licença
eles foram presos em bicicleta todos os
problemas é o supervisor que que vai
resolver
e nesse ano em 2010 só isso eu estava
mesmo a viver de supervisora e é verdade
estava com o moral em alta pensar já em
dois anos a academia lá fitness lado de
todos lavam um projeto pioneiro
certamente vou conseguir ser supervisor
brasil uma postura de convencido da tam
em nota que eu só para estudo e é
verdade é que correu mal e não fiz foi
assinado em quatro participantes
nós éramos fãs selecionados outros dois
pensei é agora o que eu vou fazer agora
vou pra um lado brasileiro e foi costume
eu pensei eu não vou conseguir seguir
supervisor bom vender novamente na rua e
neste caso já está a viver em lisboa foi
nos lados para o jardim zoológico de
lisboa e teve com o carro na água com o
carro lá e vi a pessoa olha o mourinho
ea nova e foi uma referência muito boa
neste caso não era viana não tenhamos
uma coisa da minha terra mas que muitos
turistas que estavam preciso um projeto
que não estavam gostando em 2016 não
conseguiremos vencer o estágio e previ
para a equipa estava no local em
portugal sendo o mais lados
vocês imaginam não é um local onde não
mais latos venda não estávamos nós
jornal não foi o sítio onde rendo mais
lado em portugal em fátima
não sei se seria mil armas em fátima
onde se vendo mais lados em portugal ea
equipa que nos ganhou na altura fez um
trabalho incansável foi uma derrota
temos que assumir que foi foi justa e
esse é um trabalho espetacular vender
atendiam cerca de
um exemplo 500 litros por dia nunca
nenhum dos lados em tentação de trocar
as placas e aí foi um trabalho não serão
incansáveis em 2017 já ir se á no início
do ano
percebam os réus continua em entrevista
anterior pertencia tenho que mudar tem
que mudar a minha forma das minhas
entrevistas e vou te dizer uma coisa
completamente diferente ea pesquisa na
internet falando que os colegas a
elaborar respostas para entrevistas
percebi que tinha falhado e finalmente
conseguir supervisão da camila ea
comissão foi um desvio algum tempo e
finja zona de coimbra até a lisboa viram
os miúdos espetacular trabalharam comigo
que foram incansáveis são martinho do
porto com isso e fizeram um trabalho
espetacular yano
como trabalho com o tamanho não tava
esperar foi convidado agora parceiro num
gestor do projeto há quatro anos vi
nascer e eu estou agora no momento não
há nenhum evento juntamente como o pedro
oliveira que nos tem dado um apoio muito
entendido uma pergunta durante o projeto
do próximo ano que vem não cheira em
2014 para um trabalho
será um projeto aprovado juntamente com
pedro tem 25 anos e tem 24
vai ser um projeto e nós vamos dar a
aposentada 400 jovens durante o verão de
assumirem a oposição defender os lados
ambulantes na rua e será uma
oportunidade certamente certamente
agarrada por todos ea mim e eu espero a
agradecimentos e novamente o convite a
alternext nunca desistam a primeira a
primeira a primeira tentativa e os times
não se excederem continuar em jean e não
sei se vou vender a mais lados eu vou
vender é se vou continuar a vender lado
mas tive que voltar pro treino e teve
que voltar a vender votos eu irei não
tem problema nenhum
ian nesse caso eu tenho e sou polícia
que se eu estudei jornalismo sabe mãe e
meu pai me pagou tudo pelo pai ou seja
se eu investi na minha formação em todos
nós temos direito de sonhar e acreditar
que vale a pena fazer aqui estamos
porque nós investimos e e temos um
direito e nesse caso não consegui mas
tofu isso fui muito feliz e abençoado
estou feliz não leva a fazer uma coisa
completamente enfrentou na área da
gestão e não tem matemática vez do meu
nono ano que vem
a ccm jornalismo e agora minha vida e
folhas de excel ea e trabalhar com a
temática tem sido um grande desafio para
mim
hum já sabem se o próximo verão um tiver
ainda não tivera nava em menos tiver
entre 18 e 25 anos e se levantar caminha
lá e vão comprovar que vender os lados é
muito mais que um trabalho do verão as
províncias e muito obrigado pelo convite
[Aplausos]
[Música]